THE STORY GOES ON, WILL NEXT SEE
YOU TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT"."
MASSIVE WILDFIRES, UNPRECEDENTED
IN THEIR SCOPE CONTINUE TO SWEEP
ACROSS HUGE PORTIONS OF THE WEST
TONIGHT.
IN OREGON, HALF A MILLION
RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
EVACUATE THEIR HOMES -- THAT’S
ONE OF EVERY TEN PEOPLE IN THE
ENTIRE STATE.
DOZENS ARE DEAD INCLUDING SMALL
CHILDREN, BUT THE FIRES STILL
ARE NOT CLOSE TO CONTAIN.
WATCH THIS REPORT FROM FOX’S
JEFF PAUL.
>> MONTHS OF DRY CONDITIONS
ADDED TWO DAYS OF HIGH WINDS AND
HOT TEMPERATURES CREATING A
PERFECT FIRESTORM ACROSS THE
WEST.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE HARDEST
HIT WITH A RECORD-BREAKING
3 BILLION ACRES BURNED AND
NEARLY 4,000 HOMES AND BUILDINGS
LOST SO FAR.
A 12-YEAR-OLD BOY AND HIS
GRANDMOTHER ARE AMONG THE LATEST
DEATHS.
THE FLAMES ARE TO SPREADING SO
FAST, IT REALLY DOESN’T GIVE
PEOPLE MUCH TIME TO GET OUT.
IF THE FIRE IS ALSO TAKING A
TOLL IN WASHINGTON STATE WHERE
MORE THAN 100 HOMES ARE GONE AND
A 1-YEAR-OLD BOY DIED AS HIS
FAMILY TRIED TO FLEE THE FLAMES.
AND IN OREGON, MORE THAN 35
FIRES ARE BURNING WITH AT LEAST
FIVE SMALL TOWNS DESTROYED.
RESOURCES ACROSS THE WEST ARE
STRETCHED THIN.
>> Tucker: IT IS AWFUL AND IT
CONTINUES AS WE SPEAK RIGHT NOW.
WALLS OF FLAME CONSUMING
EVERYTHING IN THEIR PATH.
UNTOLD NUMBERS OF ANIMALS, HOMES
AND AS WE SAID, HUMAN BEINGS
TOO.
IT IS TRAGEDY ON A MASSIVE SCALE
BUT SOMETHING THIS TERRIBLE
HAPPENS, DECENT PEOPLE PAUSE,
THEY PUT THEIR OWN INTERESTS
ASIDE FOR A MOMENT, THEY
CONSIDER HOW THEY CAN HELP.
WE’VE SEEN THAT KIND OF
SELFLESSNESS BEFORE IN THIS
COUNTRY, THIS IS, REMEMBER, THE
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11, BUT THERE
ARE OTHERS FOR WHOM ALTRUISM IS
AN UNKNOWN CONCEPT,
SELF-INTEREST IS ALL THEY KNOW.
THESE PEOPLE RELENTLESSLY PRESS
FORWARD FOR ANY ADVANTAGE UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
THEY SEEK HUMAN SUFFERING AS A
MEANS TO INCREASE THEIR PERSONAL
POWER.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO TURNED
FUNERALS INTO POLITICAL RALLIES
AND FEEL NO SHAME FOR DOING THAT
THAT.
AS AMERICANS BURNED TO DEATH,
PEOPLE LIKE THIS SWUNG INTO
ACTION IMMEDIATELY, THEY WANTED
TO TELEVISION FOR THE TALKING
POINTS.
CLIMATE CHANGE, THEY SAID,
BECAUSE THESE FIRES.
THEY DIDN’T EXPLAIN HOW EXACTLY
THAT HAPPENED, HOW TO CLIMATE
CHANGE DO THAT?
THEY DIDN’T TELL US BUT THEY
JUST KEPT SAYING IT.
IN THE HANDS OF DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS, CLIMATE CHANGES
LIKE SYSTEMIC RACISM IN THE SKY.
YOU CAN’T SEE IT BUT REST
ASSURED IT’S EVERYWHERE AND IT
IS DEADLY.
LIKE SYSTEMIC RACISM, IT IS YOUR
FAULT.
THE AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS DID
IT, THEY CAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE.
THEY EAT TOO MANY HAMBURGERS,
THEY DROVE TOO MANY SUVs, THEY
HAD TOO MANY CHILDREN.
A LOT OF THEM WEAR T-SHIRTS TO
WORK AND DIDN’T IN HIS COLLEGE,
THAT CAUSES CLIMATE CHANGE TOO.
WORST OF ALL, SOME OF THE MAY
VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP IN
NOVEMBER.
AND IF THERE’S ANYTHING THAT
ABSOLUTELY, DEFINITIVELY CAUSES
CLIMATE CHANGE, LITERALLY OVER
100% OF SCIENTISTS AGREE WITH
THIS ESTABLISHED FACT, IT IS
VOTING FOR DONALD TRUMP, YOU
MIGHT AS WELL START A TIRE FIRE
IN YOUR YARD.
JOE BIDEN HAS CHECKED THE
SCIENCE AND HE AGREES WITH THIS.
YESTERDAY THE PEOPLE ON BIDEN’S
STAFF WHO UNDERSTAND THE
INTERNET TWEETED OUT AN IMAGE OF
THE WILDFIRES ALONG WITH THIS
MESSAGE "CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ALREADY HERE AND WE ARE
WITNESSING ITS DEVASTATING
EFFECTS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE HAVE TO GET PRESIDENT TRUMP
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE."
ONCE AGAIN, BY VOTING FOR
DONALD TRUMP, YOU ARE CAUSING
CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH CAUSES
DEVASTATING FIRES.
YOU, BYY YOUR BOAT, HAVE MADE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
OREGONIANS HOMELESS TONIGHT,
YOU’VE MURDERED PEOPLE.
JOE BIDEN’S CLOSEST FRIEND IN
THE WORLD, A PROMINENT KITE
SURFER ON MARTHA’S VINEYARD
CALLED BARACK OBAMA, ECHOED THAT
MESSAGE WITH HIS TRADEMARK
RESTRAINT.
HE DECLARED YOUR LIFE DEPENDS ON
VOTING FOR JOE BIDEN.
HOLD ON A MINUTE, YOU MIGHT ASK,
DOESN’T THIS VERY SAME
BARACK OBAMA OWN A $12 MILLION
SPREAD RIGHT ON THE OCEAN IN
MASSACHUSETTS?
AT A TIME WHEN SEA LEVELS ARE
RISING SO FAST WE ARE ABOUT TO
SEE KILLER WHALES IN THE
ROCKIES -- THAT DOESN’T MAKE
SENSE.
IT DOESN’T SEEM LIKE
BARACK OBAMA COULD BE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
BY THE WAY, DIDN’T HE GO TO LAW
SCHOOL?
WHEN DID HE BECOME A SCIENTIST?
DOES SEEM LIKE REASONABLE
QUESTIONS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, LAWYERS
PRETENDING TO BE SCIENTISTS ARE
NOW EVERYWHERE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HERE FOR EXAMPLE IS THE GOVERNOR
OF WASHINGTON STATE, JAY INSLEE.
HE’S A PROUD GRADUATE OF
WILLAMETTE LAW SCHOOL.
>> THESE ARE CONDITIONS
EXACERBATED BY THE CHANGING
CLIMATE WE ARE SUFFERING AND I
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
SURRENDER THESE SUBDIVISIONS OR
THESE HOUSES TO CLIMATE CHANGE
EXACERBATED FIRES.
WE SHOULD FIGHT THE CAUSE OF
THESE FIRES.
>> Tucker: SO I MISMANAGE MY
STATE, NOW IT’S ON FIRE, YOU’RE
REQUIRED TO GIVE ME MORE POWER.
YOU SEE HOW THAT WORKS.
AS A FACTUAL MATTER, THIS IS A
CROCK.
THERE’S NOT A SINGLE SCIENTIST
ON EARTH WHO KNOWS WHETHER OR BY
HOW MUCH THESE FIRES MAY HAVE
BEEN EXACERBATED BY WARMER
TEMPERATURES CAUSED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE.
ALL WE HAVE IS CONJECTURE FROM A
HANDFUL OF SCIENTISTS AND MANY
POLITICIANS, NONE OF WHOM HAVE
REACHED A DEFINITIVE CONCLUSION.
DANIEL SWAIM A SCIENTIST AT UCLA
CONCEDED ITS HARD TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CLIMATE CHANGE PLAYED A
ROLE IN SPARKING THE FIRES --
OKAY.
THAT’S WHAT SCIENCE IS.
IT’S GRADUAL, INCREMENTAL, OFTEN
IT’S TENTATIVE.
WE DON’T SAY THINGS WE DON’T
KNOW FOR CERTAIN, IT’S THE
OPPOSITE OF POLITICS.
THEY HAVE NOTHING IN COMMON.
MEANWHILE BACK IN THE MATERIAL
WORLD, INVESTIGATORS HAVE THE
TERM OF EL DORADO FIRE WAS
CAUSED BY PEOPLE SETTING UP SOME
KIND OF FIREWORKS.
THEN ON WEDNESDAY POLICE
ANNOUNCED A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION IS UNDERWAY INTO
THE MASSIVE ALAMEDA FIRE IN
ASHLAND, OREGON, THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE STATE.
THE SHERIFF THEY ARE SAID IT’S
TOO EARLY TO SAY WHAT CAUSED THE
FIRE BUT HE DID SAY HUMAN
REMAINS WERE FOUND AT THE
SUSPECTED ORIGIN OF IT, SO
NOTHING IS BEING RULED OUT
TONIGHT INCLUDING ARSON.
AS ALWAYS WITH THESE THINGS THE
MORE YOU KNOW, THE MORE FACTS,
THE MORE DETAILS YOU KNOW, THE
MORE COMPLICATED IT BECOMES.
SERIOUS PEOPLE -- AND THERE ARE
STILL SOME -- ARE JUST BEGINNING
TO GATHER EVIDENCE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THIS STARTED AND THINKING
THROUGH HOW TO PREVENT IT GOING
FORWARD.
AT THE SAME TIME, UNFORTUNATELY,
OUR MEDIA ARE GIVING VOICE TO
DEEPLY UNSERIOUS PEOPLE,
PARTISAN PEOPLE AND THEY ARE ON
TELEVISION DROWNING OUT
NUANCE -- DON’T WORRY ABOUT THE
FACTS, JUST TRUST US.
THE SKY IS ORANGE OVER
SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE HOUSEHOLDS
MAKING 40 GRAND A YEAR MADE THE
MISTAKE OF VOTING REPUBLICAN.
THEREFORE, YOU MUST GIVE US
TOTAL CONTROL OF THE NATION’S
ECONOMY -- THE GREEN NEW DEAL IS
MANDATORY NOW.
WATCH MR. ARSON DETECTIVE
NANCY PELOSI EXPLAIN.
>> MOTHER EARTH IS ANGRY, SHE’S
TELLING US WHETHER WITH
HURRICANES ON THE GULF COAST,
FIRES IN THE WEST, WHATEVER IT
IS THAT CLIMATE CRISIS IS REAL
AND HAS AN IMPACT.
>> Tucker: MOTHER NATURE IS
ANGRY?
PLEASE.
ONE IS THE LAST TIME
NANCY PELOSI WENT OUTSIDE.
COULD SHE IDENTIFY A SINGLE
TREE?
NO ONE ASKED HER OF COURSE.
ALL WE KNOW IS WHAT SHE SAID
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE CAUSED
THIS -- OF COURSE IT DID THAT.
BECAUSE NO MATTER WHAT THE
NATURAL DISASTER IS, HURRICANES,
TORNADOES, ACNE, WHATEVER --
CLIMATE CHANGE DID IT, IN OTHER
WORDS, YOU DID IT.
AND TO REPENT FOR DOING IT, YOU
NEED TO GIVE US FULL CONTROL OF
YOUR LIFE.
KEEP IN MIND THE PERSON TELLING
US THIS OWNS AT LEAST TWO SUB
ZERO FREEZERS, EACH ONE COSTS
$10,000.
THEY USE A LOT OF ENERGY.
AND LIKE BARACK OBAMA, LIKE A
JOE BIDEN, NANCY PELOSI
CONSTANTLY FLIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY PRIVATELY BETWEEN HER
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR ESTATES.
IF SHE CARED ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE, SHE WOULD BE DOING
THAT -- SHE DOESN’T COME ANOTHER
TO HER SUPPORTERS.
OTHERWISE THEY WOULD BE MASSED
OUTSIDE OF HER ESTATES IN ANGER.
THEY WOULDN’T BE TRYING TO
DESTROY THE HAIR SALON THAT
EXPOSED HER HYPOCRISY.
IS NOT ABOUT SCIENCE, IT’S
CERTAINLY NOT ABOUT THE EARTH.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO DON’T GO
OUTSIDE, THEY KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
NATURE.
IT’S ABOUT RITUALLY HUMILIATING
THE AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS FOR
DARING TO ELECT SOMEBODY THEY
DON’T LIKE.
JOE BIDEN KNOWS THAT
PENNSYLVANIA’S WOULD BE
FINANCIALLY RUINED BY THE
FRACKING BAN WOULD BE THE SAME
PENNSYLVANIANS WHO FLIPPED IT
READ IN 2016 FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN A GENERATION CAP YOU THINK
THEY ARE HOLDING A GRUDGE?
YOU BUT THEY ARE.
ONE OF THE REASONS HE DOESN’T GO
OUTSIDE IS WHEN HE DOES HE HAS A
TENDENCY TO SHOW PURE,
UNDISGUISED CONTEMPT FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS HE SUPPOSEDLY CARES
DEEPLY ABOUT.
IN 2019, HE OPENLY MOCKED COAL
MINERS.
HE SUGGESTED THEY GET
PROGRAMMING JOBS ONCE THEY ARE
ALL FIRED, WATCH.
>> I COME FROM A FAMILY WHERE
THERE’S COAL MINE, IN SCRANTON.
ANYBODY CAN GO DOWN 300 FEET IN
THE MIND CAN LEARN TO PROGRAM AS
WELL.
>> Tucker: "LEARN TO CODE,"
HILARIOUS.
IF JOE BIDEN SHOULD LEARN TO
CODE, KEEP US POSTED ON HOW THAT
GOES.
THERE IS NO TIME FOR THAT, THE
WORLD IS ENDING.
THERE’S NO TIME TO PAUSE AND
SAVOR THE DEEP LAYERS OF
HYPOCRISY HERE.
WE ARE MEASURING OUR LIVES AND
MINUTES NOW.
LAST SUMMER, SANDY CORTEZ DID
THE MATH ON ALL OF THIS AND SHE
CALCULATED WE ONLY HAVE 12 YEARS
LEFT TO LIVE.
>> THE WORLD IS GOING TO END IN
12 YEARS IF WE DON’T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE, THIS IS OUR
WORLD WAR II.
>> Tucker: THAT SOUNDS BAD BUT
ACTUALLY IT’S WORSE THAN THAT,
MUCH WORSE THAN THAT -- CONSIDER
THIS.
JUST FOUR MONTHS AFTER SHE GAVE
US THAT WARNING, SHE TWEETED WE
ONLY HAVE TEN YEARS TO CUT
CARBON EMISSIONS IN HALF.
THINK ABOUT THAT, WE LOST TWO
YEARS AND JUST FOUR MONTHS.
AT THAT RATE, WE COULD LITERALLY
ALL BE DEAD UNLESS JOE BIDEN
WINS IN NOVEMBER WHICH IS OF
COURSE WHAT THEY ARE SAYING
UNDERNEATH IT ALL.
ON TUESDAY, CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM SAID IT
OUT LOUD, SCIENCE IS TOO
STRINGENT FOR GAVIN NEWSOM, TO
WESTERN INTO PATRIARCHAL.
HE’S NOW A MAN OF FAITH.
HE’S DECIDED THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
CAUSED ALL OF THIS AND THAT IS
FINAL, HE’S NOT LISTENING TO ANY
OTHER ARGUMENTS, WATCH.
>> I HAVE NO PATIENCE AND I SAY
THIS LOVINGLY, NOT AS AN
IDEOLOGUE BUT AS SOMEONE WHO
PRIDES HIMSELF IN BEING OPEN TO
ARGUMENT, INTERESTED IN EVIDENCE
BUT I QUITE LITERALLY HAVE NO
PATIENCE FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
DENIERS.
IT SIMPLY FOLLOWS, COMPLETELY
INCONSISTENT, THAT POINT OF VIEW
WITH THE REALITY ON THE GROUND.
>> Tucker: I’M NOT AN
IDEOLOGUE BUT ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES WITH ME MUST BE
IGNORED AND ELIMINATED, I DON’T
WANT TO HEAR ANY COUNTERVAILING
FACTS OR EVIDENCE, NONE.
BUT I’M NOT AN IDEOLOGUE.
PEOPLE LIKE GAVIN NEWSOM, THEY
DON’T WANT TO LISTEN TO CLIMATE
CHANGE DENIERS WHICH RAISES THE
CENTRAL QUESTION, WHAT IS A
CLIMATE CHANGE DENIER?
IT’S ANYONE WHO THINKS OUR
RULING CLASS HAS DONE A VERY
POOR JOB RUNNINGNG THEIR STATES,
RUNNING THEIR COUNTRY,
PROTECTING THE PEOPLE THEY WERE
HIRED TO PROTECT AND WATCH OVER.
ARE WE CLIMATE CHANGE DENIERS IF
WE POINT OUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS FAILED TO
IMPLEMENT MEANINGFUL
DEFORESTATION MEASURES THAT
MIGHT HAVE DRAMATICALLY EXPLODED
THE SPREAD OF THESE WILDFIRES?
DOES THAT MAKE US DENIERS?
IN 2018, THE STATE OVERSIGHT
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA FOUND THAT
YEARS OF POOR OR NONEXISTENT
FOREST MANAGEMENT POLICY AND THE
SEA THE SIERRA NEVADA FOREST HAD
CONTRIBUTED TO THE FIRES.
ONE OF THE FEW REPUBLICANS WHO
STILL HOLDS OUR ELECTED OFFICE
IN THAT STATE LAST YEAR CALLED
ON USING THE STATES $22 BILLION
BUDGET SURPLUS -- PROBABLY LAST
WHEN ITS HISTORY -- TO IMPLEMENT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT BECAUSE
FIRES OBVIOUS THEY DON’T SPREAD
AS WELL IF THEY ARE CONNECTED BY
HUGE FORESTS.
ALL OF THAT IS OBVIOUS WHICH
MEANS YOU CAN’T SAY IT OUT LOUD.
THE NATURAL WORLD IS ANATHEMA TO
IDEOLOGUES LIKE THIS.
PRESUMABLY YOU’RE ALSO A CLIMATE
CHANGE DENIER IF YOU POINT OUT
THAT SIX OF THE OREGON
NATIONAL GUARD’S WILD FIRE
FIGHTING HELICOPTERS AREN’T IN
OREGON ANYMORE, THEY ARE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
INSTEAD OF DROPPING WATER TO
SUPPRESS THE BLAZES, THEY ARE
BUSY SUPPLYING THE WAR EFFORT
THAT’S BEEN GOING ON FOR NEARLY
20 YEARS FOR NO REASON.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN, AND WHAT IS
THE EFFECT OF IT?
THOSE MIGHT BE GOOD QUESTIONS TO
ASK OF GAVIN NEWSOM, JAY INSLEE,
THE GOVERNOR OF OREGON -- DOES
ANYONE EVEN CARE MUST MAKE THE
ANSWER IS OF COUOURSE NOBODY CAR
ABOUT THE DETAILS AT ALL.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE LIVES
OF THE PEOPLE THEY GOVERN, THEY
DON’T CARE ABOUT FACTS, THEY
DON’T CARE ABOUT SCIENCE.
IT WAS JUST LAST WEEK AT THE
MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES ERIC
GARCETTI ADMITTED ON THE RECORD
THAT L.A. HAS BECOME COMPLETELY
THIRD WORLD, WHICH IT HAS
UNFORTUNATELY.
OF COURSE HE DIDN’T BLAME
HIMSELF FOR THE DEGRADATION OF
ONE OF THE GREAT AMERICAN CITIES
THAT HE RUNS, NO.
HE BLAMED YOU, YOU DID IT.
"IT’S ALMOST 3:00 P.M., TIME TO
TURN OFF MAJOR APPLIANCES.
SET THE THERMOSTAT TO 78 DEGREES
OR USE A FAN INSTEAD, TURN OFF
EXCESS LIGHTS AND UNPLUG ANY
APPLIANCES YOU’RE NOT USING.
WE NEED EVERY CALIFORNIAN TO
HELP CONSERVE ENERGY, PLEASE DO
YOUR PART."
YOU’VE GOT TO WONDER IF YOU ARE
ABLE TO GO TO HIS HOUSE, WHICH
ARE NOT, CAN’T GET PAST THE
BODYGUARDS YOU PAY FOR, IS HE
FOLLOWING THESE RECOMMENDATIONS?
NO.
IT’S NOT ABOUT HIM, IT’S ABOUT
THE PEOPLE HE SUPPOSED TO BE
HELPING, THE ONES HE’S NOW
BLAMING.
HE WANTS THEM TO SUFFER SO THAT
HE AND HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS --
EVEN NOW AS RESIDENTS ARE FACING
SWEEPING POWER OUTAGES IN
ADDITION TO THE WILDFIRES, IN
THE MEANTIME GAVIN NEWSOM HAS
FOUND 50% OF CALIFORNIA’S GRID
WILL BEE BASED ON RENEWABLE
SOURCES IN A D DECADE, THAT MEAN
SOURCES LIKE WIND AND SOLAR
POWER.
THE TRUTH IS YOU CAN’T DIAL UP
WIND OR SOLAR IN MOMENTS OF
EXTREME DEMAND FOR MOMENTS LIKE
RIGHT NOW, DURING A HEAT WAVE
SWEEPING CALIFORNIA.
GAVIN NEWSOM WAS ASKED WHETHER
HE WOULD CONSIDER REVISING HIS
STANCE GIVEN THAT THE BLACKOUTS
HAVE LEFT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT POWER AND
POSITIVELY KILLED PEOPLE AND
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENS.
HE RESPONDED THIS WAY.
"WE ARE GOING TO RADICALLY
CHANGE THE WAY WE PRODUCE AND
CONSUME ENERGY."
IN OTHER WORDS, NO, WE ARE